let's bring in ben dominic he's the
publisher
of the federalist so ben america's
largest school district
has decided to close down because the
positivity rate for
coronavirus in this area has hit
a an arbitrary number of three percent
over a seven day rolling average the
world health organization
says five percent is probably the point
at which you close the schools what's
going on here
what's going on is i think that in the
aftermath of the 2020
election uh the news media is finally
waking up to the fact
that andrew cuomo covers up his
incompetence with a lot of bluster
that he just gets aggressive and angry
as opposed to responding to what i
agree was just very straightforward
questions about what's going to happen
you you look over across on the other
side of the atlantic
and you see in france and germany
they're experiencing significant spikes
right now
they're locking down a lot of things you
know what they aren't locking down and
closing
schools and that's because we have all
types of research now that we didn't
have
last spring and summer about the fact
that schools are not a source of major
spread of this coronavirus
that's something that is a good thing
and it's something that teachers should
be
able to respond to and and that parents
should be able to respond to
with a lot of optimism and hope instead
what we're learning
is that one of the exceptional things
about america unfortunately
is the power of these teachers unions
politically
to get what they want out of these
scenarios as opposed to putting kids
first
and the the prospect i have to say of
kids
losing an entire year of schooling to
this
this type of false teaching of this of
this you know
blended learning and the like uh is
really of
enormous concern not just you know to me
but i think to all americans about the
future that these kids
are going to have if we don't turn
things around
ben i want to play one more soundbite of
the governor this is governor cuomo
blaming all the new yorkers listen
if you socially distanced and you wore a
mask and you were smart
none of this would be a problem it's all
self-imposed it's all self-imposed
if you didn't eat the cheesecake you
wouldn't have a weight problem
ben your reaction was it self-imposed
when the andrew cuomo made the decision
that put so many people locked down in
nursing homes
that wasn't self-imposed it comes from
government and in the same way that this
decision about the school system in new
york comes from government
it's not something that's self-imposed
those kids didn't eat the cheesecake
this is not a situation where he can
shift this off onto other people when
the responsibility really is his people
are looking
to our political leaders in this moment
for responsible leadership
not bluster not hiding from the actual
consequences of their decisions
instead saying hey we've learned a lot
about this one thing that we have
learned is that schools can be open
and that we can deal with this in you
know minimizing
the risk to children and in all sorts of
different approaches
that avoid them having the kind of level
of fears
that we had before we knew as much as we
know now about this virus like every
columnist in the new york times nicholas
kristoff even wrote president trump was
right
to say keep schools open and in the new
york times story
they write today that kids need to be
socialized one in eight kids are living
in it with a parent with some type of
addiction and school is a refuge it's
often the only
uh the only meal they get they need the
socialization at a young age
and mckinsey and company for those older
kids they need it too
they say that they will say on on
average they project that one million
kids will drop out of school
because of this prolonged remote
learning it is unbelievable that he will
blame
us for a worldwide pandemic that has
brought to its knees
170 plus countries and he says
new yorkers aren't worthy of him the
arrogance of a guy that missed
17 meetings with the white house on how
to coordinate
coronavirus aid and ppe
to sit there and say we are not worthy
of him
ben i can't overstate how the lack of
self-awareness and
and uh and ego out of control he is
emblematic of that
well and he's gotten away with it to
this point because people like nick
kristoff
saved their you know acknowledgement
that donald trump trump was right about
something until after the election
everything was in the context
of you know getting through this
election from the perspective of of the
media and i think that in this case
we're finally hearing the truth which is
that yes this is something where you
know it makes us feel uncomfortable at
the new york times to agree with
president trump about something
but he was right about this just as all
the other people pushing uh for schools
to reopen were right about this
and you know cuomo is not going to get
away i think with this continued blame
shifting he's gotten away from it
with it for far too it's not a book tour
but people are waking up he's selling a
book every day
that it is pathetic it is ridiculous and
keep in mind he's about to get a 25
000 raise so it's one of these
situations where look
this is this is the worst kind of
leadership that we could have in this
moment
it's unserious it's wrong it's making
decisions not based on science
but based on this kind of blustery
attitude and i hope that people are
actually waking up to it that new
yorkers will respond to it and that they
will push back against him to the point
that he has to change maybe he should
tell his brother to wear a mask too
because his brother forgot to wear it
for seven months ben
let's go to the other coast let's talk
about california and gavin newsom and
we've discovered the hypocrisy
of him going to that fancy birthday
dinner for
a lobbyist with the california
medical association the cma and not only
was the lobbyist there
but apparently the ceo of the cma dustin
corcoran was there
they say they followed the state and
local guidelines but you look at this
stuff and you think wait
they're telling us we can't really leave
our house we've got to wear a mask we
shouldn't travel and things like that
but when you look for leadership on
personal responsibility
it doesn't seem you can look to the
governor of california who said
a couple of days ago yeah i blew it and
you can't look to the
california medical association either
because their top
guy was sitting four inches from
somebody on his left and somebody on his
right
you know i look at that picture and to
me that looks like a nice thanksgiving
dinner it does exactly the kind of drink
that he's not allowing californians to
have
and so i mean it's the type of look you
know this is
thanksgiving the holidays these are
really important to a lot of americans
it's a
it's a time when we can be grateful even
after times of
great and terrible challenge i mean that
was the context obviously
of the first thanksgiving which we at
the federalists have a series running
about
right now the 1620 project about the
pilgrims about the lessons you can learn
from them
but in this case in this case gavin knew
some hypocrisy
i appreciate so much the woman who took
these pictures because without these
pictures he would have gotten away with
spinning this
and with pretending like he didn't do
anything wrong the fact that we had
someone who just
you know recognized the governor said
that doesn't look right and
snapped a couple of these pictures that
we can look at thanks to your colleagues
out there at
fox uh l.a that to me is is
the highest level of hypocrisy it should
be called out i better get
the word he lied in his apology he said
it was an
outdoor event they don't hang
chandeliers from trees
you know i do want to say one word which
is that my sympathy goes out to the
folks who actually work hard i'm sure
at french laundry and at all of the
restaurants across the country
that have been dealing with these
challenges the restaurant industry is
smashed by this as you all know and
they're just trying to do their jobs
right and for him to
kind of shift this blame or to pretend
like you know this was
no big deal or that you know he this is
a situation that
we we should all be able to have the
kind of meal that gavin newsom had i
think that we should
all be able to do this we had 450
dollars for dinner
i think we could all use it yeah
absolutely absolutely i think what
people are upset with is
is just that he's preaching one thing
and doing another
all right all right thank you ben